a delay in the delivery of oxygen to a
hospital in the city of peshawar
is being blamed for the deaths of
several coronavirus patients
they'd relied on oxygen to stay alive at
the kaiba teaching hospital
but with no backup supply they died
shortly
after it was cut the minister of health
of the pashtun province
tweeted a preliminary report from the
hospital that showed failures
in many areas it cites a lack of oxygen
for several months
and cylinders not being completely
filled it says this went unnoticed
unsupervised and unchecked staff are
also absent at the hospital's oxygen
plant
transparency compromise there will be no
compromise
on transparency action should be tough
and fair and bring back the credibility
of the hospital to our masses
we tried our best in making the report
public in as little time as possible
this sad incident will help put us in
the right direction for the future
strategy
of health care although staff members
have been suspended
some analysts say this reflects a
government failure to prepare for the
pandemic
this incident is a
reflects carelessness callousness
criminal negligence as such disaster
management
one of the essentials is preparedness
and then mitigation in that case
i would say uh the government of hebrew
in particular and the government of
pakistan
have visibly failed as for preparedness
is concerned
the world health organization in
november praised pakistan for its fight
against the pandemic
saying it had taken appropriate measures
to control infections in maine june
it worked with the country to set up
labs and to be able to test 50
000 people a day but so far only around
two percent of pakistan's population of
around 220 million people
has been tested for the virus back in
bashawa
as an investigation is underway many
want to know why there were so many
failures
and how they all seem to go unnoticed
law about a manly al jazeera